notre invité politique ce matin c'est ce
fait qu'ils elles dont jours beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur internet a chargé
des personnes handicapées vous êtes
également tête de liste la république en
marche aux régionales dans la région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur on va bien
sûr parler de votre candidature
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
des interviews en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale bonjour
favoriser le cerveau donc bonjour oriane
dont jouissent les journaux du groupe
ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france et on commence bien sûr sophie
cluzel par la crise sanitaire et cette
barre symbolique des cent mille morts
qui a donc été franchi hier soir
emmanuel macron qui a dit qu'il y aura
un hommage aux victimes sans en préciser
la forme ça fait un an que la france
compte malheureusement ces morts
quotidiens pourquoi avoir attendu
pourquoi attendre pour cet hommage car
déjà on n'attend pas pour pour le rendre
hommage au quotidien à ces familles que
à qui j'adresse vraiment tout toute ma
compassion et puis je les vois dans
régulièrement puisque je circule
beaucoup et puis surtout j'ai j'ai
énormément de familles en visio
composent concernés par par céder c'est
donc une grande émotion une grande
émotion pour pour ces familles touchées
dans leur chair
on leur rend moi je régulièrement et je
pense que symboliquement c'est vrai que
il faut c'est certainement un geste
important que la nation leur doit à elle
et puis bien sûr aussi saluer tous les
soignants qui ont été à leurs côtés dans
ces moments extrêmement difficiles de
fin de vie compliquée sur lequel ben
justement la notion de deuil n'a pas pu
être fait un an de un nom de co vide
on rappelle donc rien de dire vous êtes
en charge des français qui sont touchés
par le handicap
est-ce que vous avez des indicateurs sur
l'état psychologique des personnes en
situation de handicap aujourd'hui en
france alors elle souffre comme tout le
monde
parfois un peu plus parce que c'est plus
difficile berne isolement accru en plus
j'imagine alors un isolement accru mais
des services extrêmement présent quand
même des services à domicile
les services d'accompagnement nous
sommes mis aussi en accompagnement maxi
pour pakasa supporter aussi des charges
administratives supplémentaires en
prorogeant tous les droits pour pâques
et des ruptures administrative c'est
important et financière et puis un mode
aussi avec le numéro de téléphone que
nous avons mis en place le 0 800 363 160
pour être en accompagnement maximale
vous avez senti par ce numéro une
détresse accrue surtout des besoins de
répit pour les familles qui ont des
personnes handicapées enfants ou adultes
chez elle des besoins de répit parce que
c'est plus difficile quand on ne peut
pas se déplacer
donc là je salue aussi les associations
qui se sont extrêmement mobilisés pour
offrir des places de répit pour offrir
par exemple du relayage à domicile c'est
possible aussi des services à domicile
extrêmement mobilisés donc nous sommes
eu un accompagnement maximale mais comme
tout le monde je veux dire il ya
vraiment une pression psychologique
importante
on va parler de la vaccination notamment
la vaccination des personnes handicapées
ferme alors est ce que aujourd'hui
on peut parler d'une priorité vaccinale
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap bien sûr l oms l on en fait
partie
sur celles qui vivent en établissement
que pour pour par exemple les foyers
d'accueil médicalisés les maisons
d'accueil spécialisées
aujourd'hui on est à près de 80% à une
vaccination est long il ya un énorme
travail de re de recueil de consentement
ce qui était très important pour celles
qui ont parfois des difficultés de pour
s'exprimer ou qui était qui sont sous
tutelle donc un très gros travail
maintenant nous travaillons sur les
personnes à domicile avec justement des
équipes mobiles qui se déplacent pour
voir les personnes les plus empêcher les
services à domicile et qui peuvent ainsi
vacciner à domicile
c'est la deuxième partie très importante
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes
isolées sur lequel il faut aller vers
donc désactiver justement un retard sur
la vaccination de ces personnes non il
n'y a pas eu de retard raisons elles ont
suivi alors on n'est pas forcément
vulnérable quand on est en situation de
handicap
il faut aussi qu'on ait des pathologies
et des comorbidités donc ça aussi c'est
important à signaler mais seuls qui
était prioritaire
elles ont été vaccinées vraiment de
façon prioritaire avec les mêmes
critères avec la même rapidité que les
que les autres à un mot sur les critères
d'âge notamment pour les aidants
familiaux
est-ce que là il faut élargir les
critères d'âge pour les aidants
familiaux
nous sommes en train d élargir mais je
veux surtout dire qu'il faut du bon sens
quand on va vacciner par exemple d'une
personne en situation de handicap chez
elle avec son aidant familial
moi j'ai dit aux équipes mobiles aux
services à domicile vacciner également
l'aidant familial
c'est important soyons pragmatiques et y
ont du bon sens et c'est comme ça qu'on
travaille le mieux mais vous allez les
élargir officiel mais vous est tout à
fait elle est comme comme lacoste et je
tiens à signaler que les foyers
d'hébergement qui ne sont pas
médicalisée sont maintenant des
dorénavant aussi prioriser on travaille
par cadencement on travaille par
priorité vous le savez c'est comme ça
qu'on est le plus efficace
donc maintenant on élargit et les
aidants familiaux ça sera à quelle
échéance dans l'est dans les quinze
jours trois semaines qui viennent on est
en train vraiment de pouvoir travailler
sur les aidants familiaux travailler sur
les personnes qui sont très isolés pour
justement aller vers ce sac est plus
important un mot sur la vaccination des
enseignants puisque
la rentrée est confirmé le 26 avril et
le 3 mai pour tout le monde en
présentiel
olivier ferrand il avait parlé de la
vaccination prioritaire pour les
enseignants qui travaillent avec des
élèves en situation de handicap
ça sera pour quand cette vaccination et
qui sera concerné exactement alors c'est
les plus de 55 ans est ce que jean
castex a annoncé aussi priorité pour
ceux qui sont au contact d'enfants en
situation de handicap
ça démarre dans les quinze jours trois
semaines ça va être annoncé un très
prochainement sur le calendrier mais en
effet ils en font partie parce que
justement c'est ces enseignants qui
s'occupe d'enfants en situation de
handicap que ce soit dans les
établissements médico sociaux que ce
soit dans les classes spécialisées
autistes ou dans les ulis qu'on appelle
les dispositifs justement qui accueille
des enfants handicapés font également
partie des personnels prioritaires c'est
ce que le premier ministre annonce est
donc ils resteront prioritaires parmi
les enseignants mais toujours avec ce
critère d'âge des 55 ans et savait ce
que le premier ministre annonce et c'est
en train de se déployer deux se préciser
et tout ça va arriver très prochainement
pour reparler des personnes âgées
ces dernières heures des familles alerté
le gouvernement sur le fait que la
vaccination se développer notamment dans
les fonds de retraite les personnels
soignants
mais les contraintes restent encore
particulièrement importante pour les
familles qui souhaitent voir c'est ces
personnes âgées
alors ça c'est beaucoup beaucoup
assouplies là il faut aussi du bon sens
ça se travaille avec la famille chaque
établissement
ça dépend si si l'on subit des clusters
si on cordes et des convalescents si on
peut dire ainsi donc là vraiment la
consigne a été de recréer ce lien ces
droits de visite
moi je le vois dans les établissements
médico sociaux pour adultes en situation
de handicap extrêmement de vigilance
bien sûr sur la sur les conditions
sanitaires
mais ce lien est indispensable et donc
les visites sont possibles
les aller retour sont possibles aussi et
c'est du cas par cas c'est vraiment du
club lens c'est à dire que oui ça dépend
aussi de l'histoire de l'établissement
qu'est ce qu'il a vécu en tant que
cluster qu'est ce qui lie est ce qui est
des personnes fragilisées par le cos
bible mais les instructions c'est clair
sont claires reste conditions sanitaires
maximale mais surtout reprendre ce droit
de visite si important et là on a aussi
des outils qui viennent par exemple les
tests salivaires
par exemple de la facilité d'obtenir ces
tests j'étais en visio par exemple à
nice avec les associations qui
travaillent avec les personnes âgées
personnes handicapées
ces tests salivaires vont être un vrai
atout à vous dites vont être parce que
pour l'instant ne te savez on en parle
beaucoup on envoie par donc non non ça y
est ils commencent à se déployer
il commence à se déployer mais une
logistique à mettre en place aussi ils
sont réservés aux plus aux enfants de
plus de 15 ans donc là aussi par exemple
pour les adultes autistes qui ne pouvait
pas supporter ces tests pcr oui
extrêmement invasif et bien ces tests
salivaires vont être un grand progrès
donc vers pouvons permettre aussi cette
liberté d'aller retour plus facilement
parce qu'on va tester plus facilement un
dernier mot sur la vaccination puisque
évidemment vous intéressé de près à ce
qui se passe dans la région sud son
président nommé joly il dit avoir
précommandé 500 mille doses de vaccin
spoutnik v qui est dans l'attenté de
l'autorisation de validation de l'agencé
européenne est-ce qu'il a eu raison car
cette précommande renaud muselier pour
vous pour moi c'est un effet de
communication
moi je suis pas dans la communication on
est dans l'action on a des règles on a
des règles sanitaires ce vaccin il a été
déposé à dix jours pour son autorisation
au sein de l'europe
elle va être validée peut-être mais en
tout cas l'important l'important c'est
de ne pas envoyer des signaux d'espoir
qui après ne pourront pas être réalisés
une fois qu'on a le vaccin c'est à
l'europe d'abord de donner
l'autorisation
et puis après c'est à la france de faire
ses commandes pour qu'on ait une équité
sur le territoire c'est quand même les
journaux vous parle pas aux régions pour
vous bien sûr que non c'est la france
qui est en quête en cours de deux
d'installation de logistique de
distribution
on a quand même à respecter une équité
territoriale tous les français doivent
avoir que avoir accès à la vaccination
et c'est bien pour ça que c'est une
dimension nationale et il n'est pas
ministre de la santé c'est la ministre
de la santé qui doit s'en occuper avec
le gouvernement on va justement parlez
de votre candidature dans la dans la
région sud qu'est ce que votre
candidature elle peut apporter à cette
région support dans sa côte d'azur
la candidature d'une femme qui est
engagée une femme qui a de la conviction
d'une femme qui représente la majorité
présidentielle fièrement élargi à la
société civile c'est mon adn
puisque c'est comme ça depuis quatre ans
que je gouverne dans ce gouvernement
et puis un projet justement
d'unification d'apaisement moi je veux
vraiment avoir une région qui est
audacieuse précieuse avec une vraie
ambition mais aussi qui ont redonné de
l'optimisme parce que comme vous l'avez
très bien dit tout à l'heure les
français ont souffert et souffre encore
on a une crise sanitaire il faut qu'on
soit prêt pour un plan de relance
économique un vrai rebond et qu'on
redonne aussi un peu d'espoir aux
français je pense que ça c'est très
important comme message qu'est ce qui se
passe on a un peu de mal à quand même à
comprendre vous avez été investi par la
république en marche et d'un autre côté
le patron des parlementaires christophe
castaner qui est un peu de la région
rappelons le est absolument mener la
région comme sa poche qui connaît bien
la région et qui connaît bien renaud
muselier aussi manifestement dit on peut
commencer à travailler ensemble dès le
premier tour avec le sortant
qu'est ce qui se passe entre la
république en marche et la droite en
place actuellement à bâbord c'est pas la
république en marche à la majorité
présidentielle et nous avons des
partenaires qui s'appelle le mode n
agirait territoire de progrès et qui
sont avec moi qui sont avec nous et hier
nous avons fait notre meeting de
lancement de campagne ils se sont
exprimés tous et notamment christophe
cristal r s'est exprimé et a apporté
largement son soutien à ce projet
comporte d'une région qui sera une
région vraiment de proximité moi je veux
changer la gouvernance de cette région
je veux vraiment quelle répondre aux
territoires qu'elle soit horizontale que
ça ne soit pas une région verticale avec
un président qui est qui qui est avec
une région qui est vraiment au service
de son trait et ça qu'on a aujourd'hui
annonce une possible liste commune dès
le premier tour non on alors il a tendu
la main en italie
écoutez bien tendu la main à renault
mais attendez ça avance et une campagne
l avance et bien il ya d'autres
partenaires qui rentre il y aura
peut-être d'autres candidats pour
l'instant lacunes
sophie cluzel donc il y aura peut-être
d'autres candidats nous on a un projet
on a un projet on a un projet
d'ouverture de notre liste je lui ai
toujours dit c'est comme ça que je
travaille depuis quatre ans d'abord à la
société civile mais aussi à toutes les
forces républicaines qui ont envie
qu'ils ont envie de bosser avec nous de
travailler sur ce projet vous êtes vous
êtes critique avec renaud muselier est
ce que ce matin je vous ai dit tu sais
ce que j'ai dit non lui tend pas la main
à ne manger donc pas la main au premier
tour ça sera chacun droit jeudi en
avance vient qui veut en toute sérénité
apaisé je ne critique pas ce n'est pas
mon adn vous n'aurez jamais entendu
vilipendé aux critiques et quelques a
jamais non pas quelqu'un mais son bilan
qu'elle je ne critique que ce qui est
critiquable
par exemple la baule et le comment de
spoutnik oui je le courage de critiques
parce que ce n'est pas la façon de faire
correctement mais en revanche moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas de critiquer au
coin c'est de proposer cette construire
et ce qui m'intéresse aussi c'est de me
lever haut et fort contre eaunes être
notre ennemi qui est le front national
ce parti de la division nationale
il faut hélas je fais appel vraiment aux
électeurs il faut venir voter parce que
l'abstention est au fait le lit aussi du
front national donc je propose
je suis avec une équipe nos partenaires
avec un christophe castaner qui a fait
un discours formidable hier de soutien
joël giraud
vous avez vu aussi florence parly qui
nous a fait une vidéo de soutien
frédéric vidal qui a peut être là parce
que elle était en réunion justement pour
préparer la sortie du confinement voilà
donc nous avons une vraie équipe
nous avons des partenaires de la société
civile des chefs d'entreprise nous avons
des élus locaux qui nous soutient une
vraie vraiment et puis surtout la
présidente de notre comité de soutien
sylvie brunet qui porte justement tous
ses soutiens
mais pour qu'on soit bien clair parce
que vous parlez du rassemblement
national on va voir ce sondage
il flotte dans votre région où
effectivement le rassemblement national
et très hauts placés et même devant au
premier tour est ce que c'est une menace
de rassemblement national
vous êtes prête à retirer votre liste
justement pour faire barrage au front
rassemblement national témoin je suis là
pour porter ce projet c'est à dire
celui-là public dès le premier tour ça
revient à dire ça
écoutez on va aller jusqu'au premier
tour puis après le second tour on verra
mais déjà on est engagés on a ouvert
notre campagne on démarre on a des
militants qui sont mobilisés on va faire
une campagne un peu particulière bien
sûr parce que d'abord il nous faut
respecter les règles sanitaires ce si
important
ex que ce qu'on demande aux français
donc ça va être beaucoup de virtuel on a
fait une première mondiale hier en
lancement de meetings avec une caméra
360 pour permettre aux gens d'arriver
comme ça en virtuel
on essaye d'innover c'est
technologiquement c'était une grande
prouesse et chômage et je vois là avec
avec bien sûr la langue des signes parce
que pour moi il est important d'avoir
une campagne qui soit en accessibilité
universelle
je veux m'adresser à tout le monde la
360 dans cette capacité d'accessibilité
universelle dont on conçoit que l'air au
premier tour chacun sa liste mais
puisque vous parliez christophe castaner
l'ue en 2015 a été retiré au second tour
c'est qu'ils ont de christian estrosi
qui est créé qui a été élu est-ce que
vous aussi si le rassemblement national
et au vous serez prête à faire enfin
barrage républicain
mais le barrage républicain était jour
toujours été notre mot d'ordre c'est à
dire un barrage au front national et
nous ouvrirait largement ma liste pour
justement faire barrage à ce front
national va être à l'avenir une
ambiguïté écoutez je pense que là je
suis concentré sur le premier tour
moi je suis là pour avancer c'est bien
ce qui a été lancé hier avec vraiment
une campagne qui est collective ça je
tiens à le dire et avec une façon de
faire de la politique autrement quand je
dis faire de la politique autrement
c'est justement accueillir accueillir
dans notre dans notre campagne
accueillir dans notre liste accueillir
dans notre projet toute personne qui a
envie de travailler avec nous et surtout
la société civile n'oublions pas la
société civile qui a envie de s'engager
on a des chefs d'entreprise des acteurs
socio économiques aux acteurs du sport
qui sont près de nous soutenir
voilà c'est mort des animaux
juste pour que pour que cela soit bien
clair si vous êtes élue présidente de
région le 27 juin prochain vous quittez
immédiatement le gouvernement alors
aujourd'hui je suis engagé en même temps
tant que ministre vous l'avais dit en
même temps tant que présidente
enfin en tant que comme pas irréalisable
notre envoyé en tant que candidate ça
fait quatre ans que je suis au
gouvernement j'ai toujours été renommé à
chaque remaniement
donc pour moi il est important de
pouvoir continuer en effet ces réformes
que j'ai engagé qui sont très bien
engagées
j'ai envie j'ai la conviction jeu que je
peux faire les deux
maintenant ce sera le président qui
décidera il n'y a pas de nom il ya c'est
a dit que vous vous dites si le
président décide évidemment vous
souhaitez rester au gouvernement jusqu'à
la fin du quinquennat finira ou la
chambre la présidence de la région non
je serai élue présidente de la région
cette question que vous me posez
j'ai la conviction que je peux faire les
deux en même temps c'est mon souhait
maintenant c'est le président qui
décidera un dernier mot sur votre
programme puisque ce matin vous dites
dans le figaro qu'il faut recoudre la
région il vous dit également vouloir une
région inclusive expliquez nous écoutez
je me suis beaucoup j'ai sillonné la
france depuis quatre ans j'ai sillonné
aussi la région quand je vois je suis
allé aux côtés des sinistrés de la
vallée de la roya mais je suis allé
partout dans la vallée du champsaur dont
je suis allé dans ces territoires qui
sont extrêmement parfois éloignés des
infrastructures des transports de la
mobilité
on sait que c'est un territoire
géographique manqué compliqué 80% sont
un peu alpa montagnards 20%
samson sont urbains et pour autant celle
inverse en terme de population
ce que j'ai vu surtout c'est que nous
avons un problème majeur pour les jeunes
pour les jeunes d'être accompagnés dans
leur dans leurs projets dans le rsa je
veux en faire une vraie cause nationale
est une brique aux régionales nous avons
un plan gouvernemental
un jeune une solution je veux que la
région provence alpes côte d'azur
puissent en profiter massivement pour
les jeunes dans tous les domaines dans
l'apprentissage dans la formation d'un
la mobilité pour moi ça sera une de mes
cause vraiment très importante sur mon
projet régional
et quand je dire qu'outre ces
territoires c'est qu'aujourd'hui bas
quand vous êtes à 36 quand vous voulez
un apprentissage par exemple au fin fond
du briançonnais et bien vous avez par
exemple sur la région rhône alpes vous
n'avez pas du tout l'accompagnement
financier nécessaire comme peut
bénéficier un apprenti qui est à
marseille nice ou toulon c'est ça sur
lequel il nous faut travailler recoudre
donner l'égalité des chances avoir la
capacité de se sortent équité
territoriale sur cette région provence
alpes côte d'azur qui a un peu perdu son
identité
le calendrier électoral va être très
connu en est sûre fin juin les deux
derniers week-ends de juin vous disais
tout à l'heure finalement que votre
principal adversaire c'est quand même
l'abstention il ya quand même un grand
risque d'abstention dans ce contexte
sanitaire
l'innovation c'est une chose mais est ce
que pour vous il ya des angles d'attaqué
ce qu'il y a des possibilités
aujourd'hui au delà de votre du
programme national pour aller chercher
ses électeurs et les amener vous à voter
il faut leur parler directement
en tout cas c'est ce que je sais faire
moi j'ai envie de changer le quotidien
des gens c'est ce que j'ai fait depuis
quatre ans en m'adressant directement
aveux en travaillant avec eux pour
construire avec eux c'est ma méthode
donc il faut qu'on trouve le moyen en
respectant les règles sanitaires
quand même pouvoir les faire du boîtage
du démarchage avait faire quelques
marchés allaient parler avec les gens
les convaincre être dans l'empathie et
sas je sais ce que c'est et les écouter
leurs problèmes quotidiens
on ne les a pas écoutés ils ont été
extrêmement isolé pour un an on a
l'occasion de renouer ce dialogue et
donc de pouvoir après les embarquer pour
aller voter en tout cas c'est ce que je
ferai c'est ce que mes équipes feront
parce que je ne suis pas tout seul bien
sûr dans tous les départements
il nous faut nous adresser directement
aux français c'est ça qu'ils attendent
de façon sereine en grande proximité et
deux questions sur vos dossiers de
secrétaire d'état aux personnes
handicapées pour terminer d'abord
l'emploi il ya un manifeste pour
l'inclusion des personnes handicapées
dans la vie économique qui a été mis en
place
est ce que vous dites aujourd'hui c'est
toujours dur d'être handicapé dans une
entreprise et est-ce qu'il faut des
mesures plus coercitives pour favoriser
l'emploi des personnes handicapées
le coercitif on l'a fait depuis 33 ans
c'est ma joie a marre et la loi
obligation d'emploi qui ne marche pas en
revanche que j'ai mis en place depuis
quatre ans ça commence à marcher parce
qu'on est passé de 3,6 à
% d'emplois dans les entreprises avec un
vrai engagement des entreprises
ces entreprises qui créent l'emploi il
nous faut les aider les accompagner
donner de la lisibilité simplifiée c'est
ce que j'ai fait avec dans la loi
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel emplois directs des
dispositifs possibles l'emploi compagnie
un plan de relance massif dead à
l'emploi d'adp al embauche directe 4000
euros je le redis projet pour toute
l'année 2000 21 ça fonctionne on a déjà
plus de 8000 comptera 60 % en cdi
et c'est comme ça que je travaillerai
avec les entreprises dans la région
provence alpes côte d'azur pas ce que je
ferais une grande mobilisation pour
mettre les entreprises en relation avec
ces jeunes et les moins jeunes aussi
parce que c'est sans limite d'âge sur
ces aides de l'apprentissage massif 8000
euros d aides à l'apprentissage ça
fonctionne on a doublé le nombre
d'apprentis en situation d'handicap
on a préservé l'emploi on le maintient
grâce à tous le job coaching qu'on met
en place donc oui les entreprises sont
impliquées se manifeste 140 entreprises
140 entreprises qui se sont engagées
toute l'année pendant le confinement je
les ai mobilisés ça porte ses fruits
c'est comme ça qu'il faut travailler et
il nous reste six minutes pour un sujet
important c'est une notice et celui de
l'autisme vous avez présenté le
quatrième plan vous êtes très investi
dans cette question et malgré tout
quatre plans et malgré tout en un
sentiment que les familles sont toujours
en aussi grande difficulté sur cette
question de l'autisme comment on peut
l'expliquer on part de très très loin en
france on à rattraper du retard ça va
jamais assez vite pour les familles et
je sais de quoi je parle
mais je peux vous dire que là on a
vraiment la bonne méthode aussi
prévention intervention précoce
on est passé plus de 150 enfants
assimilent with an enfants qui ont été
repérés parce que le repérage précoce
c'est cela j'étais avec le président de
la république la semaine dernière pour
justement aller visiter ses plates
formes d'intervention précoce
nous avons échangé avec la famille nous
sommes engagés sur la prise en charge
financière des frais qui n'étaient pas
pris en charge avant il y avait une
injustice une inéquité sur le traitement
justement des prises en charge de
psychologie de d'ergo de psychomotricité
nous avons rattrapé cela maintenant il
nous faut absolument travailler sur les
adultes les adultes qui ont un autiste
sévère nous créons des petites unités
justement pour ce vie
ensemble et pour cet accompagnement
massif nous rattrapons du retard nous
avons remis de la science nous sommes
enfin en capacité d'avoir les projets
européens pour la recherche des causes
de l'autisme
ça sera un sujet majeur justement
pendant la présidence française de
l'europe
nous avançons jamais assez vite pour les
familles c'est certain mais une très
grande progression est aussi nous avons
pas parlé de ça mais dans les crèches
dans la scolarisation donc le chemin est
tracé
nous avançons et toujours il faut
avancer plus vite sur cette côte et ce
sera le mot de la fin merci sophie
cluzel merci d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin merci fabrice enderlin du dauphiné
cent mille morts qui sont ils c'est une
question qui est à lire dans beaucoup de
journaux du groupe ebra aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup
[Musique]